un truc de fou quoi
alors je prends la mesure attends
attends après le café je prendrai un
dessert faut que je Twitter un mec qui
se fait taper exactement
parce qu'on donneront les les coupables
sans sans pitié allez remets-moi une
tarte tatin la politique
[Applaudissements]
ils vont Twitter pour ta place
ça fait du bien
tu peux me faire Guillaume tu peux me
faire un twitch s'il te plaît là il
paraît qu'il y a un meilleur qui fait
passer un tabac donc qu'est-ce qu'il
fait
mais prenez votre temps la justice elle
est pas trop vite prenez votre temps moi
je suis d'accord il y a pas de problème
bah tu es consterné par la vie mais non
mais
on vient tous les soirs avec tous les
soirs tu rencontres ce qu'on prend dans
la gueule tu as parlé de Lindsay Lola
machin et à chaque fois il vient à la
télé 3 semaines après ah bon ça a
chauffé là ouais parce que nous elle a
foutu le bordel faut que tu y ailles là
mais ça fait trois semaines qu'on était
caché comment ça se fait que ouais mais
là il a fait venir les parents ça a
chial et toi maintenant faut que tu
ailles il a faut sortir du bois ça sort
du bois et après ça passe à quelle
époque et après ça passe à BFM mais
après ça passe par exemple au lieu de
passer à la télé au lieu de venir là
venez par là et faites des choses faites
des choses prenez des
[Applaudissements]
je veux pas que les affaires elles
existent qui nous cite pas ou qui fasse
leur travail de journaliste et d'aller
chercher les affaires qui se réveille
les histoires c'est bengous qui sort les
histoires c'est machin c'est Maurice qui
sort les histoires c'est Jean-Paul ils
font quoi les journalistes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et les ministres mais non tu me chauffes
mais c'est pas bien